hey this is really funny um we have a
voicemail number
2192 david p and
a trump voter was not pleased with one
of our videos from last week that went
viral
because i was in a different location
last week and he didn't like the size of
my
microphone take a listen to this
yeah i stumbled across your show
you were commenting on donald trump and
um the hannity show
so on so forth i think it's pretty weak
you it just sounds so
weak man put it put a a
picture on the wall from your parents
bedroom there
pretty drab and uh you got a big giant
microphone
what the hell who are you man
you're weak all right keep going keep
going man we'll just follow the
commenting
as you guys lose the election again
all right see you later all right see
you later
um it's funny when people call in they
take the time they've clearly watched
enough to
issue a very specific critique they call
in
to tell me how unimportant and and lame
everything i'm doing is
and the criticism is the size of my
microphone
and the fact that i didn't have the
place i was broadcasting from last week
sufficiently decorated to their standard
you know it's a
uh if you want to talk about a weak
criticism that's what it sounds like to
me but i love it i love it we had
200 new voicemails over the weekend
still going through them and
a lot of action a lot of action make
sure to subscribe to us on youtube we
are
racing to 1 million youtube subscribers
make sure that you get our daily audio
podcast on
any platform which you prefer whether
it's spotify
pandora google play itunes
iheartradio what else is there stitcher
anyway we've also got a great bonus show
coming up for you today and i invite you
to grab a membership
at joinpackman.com to get instant access
to today's bonus show